Hello latin america i'm anthony mackey
i'm sebastian stan we hope you will enjoy
watching the falcon and winter soldier
series who will take over captain america
shield you'll have to watch to find out check
it out on disney plus only on disney plus
hi latino america i'm elizabeth
olsen hello latino america
we invite you to enjoy Wandavision and
uh we promise you it's going to be a
feast for your eyes keep you on your toes only
available on disney plus only on disney plus
hola latin america you know marvel superheroes
face a lot of challenges but none quite as
challenging as figuring out what to watch next on
disney plus welcome back everyone it's charlie we
have a new Wandavision trailer new falcon and
winter soldier trailer they just posted because
they're releasing disney plus in latin america we
also have some more details about what's going on
with them actually releasing episodes i've also
got some more falcon and winter soldier footage
with a bunch of easter eggs so we'll break it
all down if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos i'll be
doing videos for all the episodes when they do
release them we're doing a disney plus giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and let me know what kind of easter eggs you want
to see on falcon and winter soldier in Wandavision
so starting with the big stuff if you didn't
see what's going on with this they just released
these falcon and winter soldier and wanda vision
clips obviously you have thor chris hemsworth in
there promoting the avengers stuff too because
as i'm posting this video they're getting ready
to release disney plus in latin american
countries and sometimes what they'll do is
for foreign releases of movies they'll cut special
trailers where the actors will do different things
you don't necessarily see them doing in the
english language versions of some of these
trailer clips so that's why you see stuff
like this pop up online it's still really
cool it would be nice if they actually
promoted the series a little bit more
this is the first official thing we've seen from
falcon and winter soldier since they released the
trailer earlier this year although there are
a bunch of clips like i said of them filming
with new villains from the series that i'll talk
about in a second that i included in the video
just a little while ago there was a small
controversy about them releasing Wandavision
episodes there was somebody claiming to have
talked to latin american disney plus help and they
were saying that they wouldn't release Wandavision
till 2021 but then right after that another user
went and asked the same latin american disney plus
helpline and they said episodes were still coming
out in 2020 so it seems like Wandavision is still
a go for 2020. so don't worry too much about that
they just finished filming last week kat dennings
who plays darcy in the thor movies is going to be
a character on the show she was talking about them
releasing episodes before the end of the year and
there were some Wandavision crew members that were
talking about releasing the series during december
but all these things just seem to point like
it's happening later in december and not earlier
because if they just finished filming episodes
in the last week it means there's still a lot
of post-production to do a lot of special
effects to add and that takes a long time
this is the crew member though that was talking
about releasing stuff in december like look out
in december things are coming normally they
would wait till after the mandalorian season 2
episodes are done but that's not actually going
to happen until the week of christmas this year
in fact they released new episodes on fridays for
all their disney plus series the friday after the
mandalorian season 2 finale is christmas day but
they're also releasing that pixar soul movie the
same day so pretty safe bet that regardless of
whether or not they double up on the first episode
of wandavision in the mandalorian episodes in the
same week whichever new Wandavision episode winds
up falling on christmas week they'll release
it a couple days earlier in the week before
friday so that they don't cannibalize the audience
for that soul movie too much they did the exact
same thing with the mandalorian season 1
episodes when it overlapped with star wars
the rise of skywalker movie in theaters just so
that fans wouldn't have to pick between watching
mandalorian or going to see rise of skywalker
the actual new Wandavision footage from behind
the scenes here makes it look like sword has moved
into scarlet witch's fake alternate reality with
their armed weapons and tanks and things have
finally escalated into all-out war in the streets
notice that the name of the town is westview it's
also the same name in that newspaper that vision
is reading inside that fake 1950s looking tv show
reality it kind of seems like a reference to west
coast avengers because there's a lot of west
coast stuff happening in the big marvel movies
during phase four like part of the shang chi
movie that we're going to be seeing next year
takes place in san francisco also where the
ant-man movies take place where ant-man 3 is going
to take place in addition to the quantum realm
of course but westview in all this misal sent
seems like it's also a bit of a reference to that
movie pleasantville with spider-man himself toby
mcguire with everything in the 1950s black and
white until toby maguire and reese witherspoon
start messing with everything and the characters
in the town start to awaken to their reality and
everything starts to change into color just like
it happens during the Wandavision trailer the
way that paul bettany talks about Wandavision
the first half of the series is all that crazy
alternate reality sitcom stuff that they do and
then the second half is when it turns into a
full-blown avengers movie with a bunch of action
scenes and from the looks of all this sword heavy
weaponry and gear this sounds like it turns into a
scarlet witch versus zack at the heartness versus
sword situation the real question though is who
the real villain of the series is going to wind up
being because if we're talking about scarlet witch
comic book easter eggs elizabeth olsen did say the
series would be an examination of scarlet witch's
mental health state in the wake of avengers end
game and vision's death so i know there have
been a bunch of theories about this it feels kind
of like a situation where the first part of the
series almost seems like scarlet witch herself is
the one that everybody is painting is the villain
of the series changing all these things refusing
to come to grips with the reality that vision is
dead and this alternate reality of hers is fake
refusing to move forward with her life but
obviously because she's supposed to be the main
protagonist of the series i think that someone
like agatha harkness or whoever agatha harkness
is working for will wind up being the real villain
they're not going to completely demonize scarlet
witch in her failing mental stability they're just
going for this really big deep cut x-men house of
m easter eggs the brand new falcon and winter
soldier footage that we have is actually of the
villains and us agent u.s agent is the antagonist
of the series but he's not the main villain
it's also one of those misleading marketing
scenarios where thunderbolt ross brings the
weapons plus program the super soldier program
out of mothballs again after we saw it in the
incredible hulk to replace captain america after
avengers end game because he's an old man now
effectively retired as iron man said during
captain america civil war that shield doesn't
belong to you technically captain america
shield is the property of the u.s government
so thunderbolt ross wants a new captain america
to be a symbol for a new era of the country and
one that he can control and that winds up being us
agent the main villain group that you see in all
this footage seems like a version of the ultimatum
group from the comics the group that flag smasher
belonged to most of the characters that will be
showing up on falcon winter soldier will be super
deep cuts from the captain america comics and
people coming back from the marvel phase 1 phase 2
phase 3 movies like first avenger captain america
winter soldier characters and civil war characters
the bigger things they're setting up in the series
in crossing over with the movies is thunderbolt
ross's creation of the thunderbolts future weapons
plus weapon x wolverine easter eggs in the mcu and
avengers 5. also too talking about winter soldier
they did say that they'd be showing off more
secret abilities that bucky's vibranium arm has it
has a lot of advanced abilities and hidden weapons
that they never really got into in avengers
infinity war in avengers end game just because
they were already so busy with the plots of those
movies right now tentatively i would assume that
falcon and winter soldier episodes are going to
be released sometime at least within a couple
months of Wandavision episodes sony promised us
a spider-man 3 teaser trailer before the end of
the year there'll probably be a new venom 2
trailer in a new morbius trailer at least by
january so there is a bunch of big stuff coming
up in addition to all the Wandavision episodes
right now of course i'm in the middle of doing
new mandalorian season 2 episodes so as long as
you have alerts enabled for my channel you should
see all those videos when i post them but everyone
click here for my new mandalorian season 2
episode 2 video and click here for that brand new
spider-man 3 tom holland clip thank you so much
for watching everyone stay safe this is the way!